[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
Mike McCarty and I'm Jake Decker
and last week we put out a video about
Metro last light Metro Exodus was
announced at Microsoft's press
conference at e3 2017 and Metro last
light its predecessor the second game
and the soon to be trilogy is one of my
favorite games ever and I think it's one
of the better shooters ever made
although I think it's underappreciated
but we decided to look at that and then
kind of look into how it continues the
legacy of half-life 2 as far as a
narrative driven first-person shooters
go I know back when they were kind of
developing last light they were talking
about how they want to rekindle memories
of half-life 2 so that's what started me
on that idea of comparing those two
games
I do take half-life 2 is a better game
we'll get into that more in the comments
in a second in the Q&A section but I do
think it pushes forward that kind of
game in an important way a little bit
under the radar game cool yeah so let's
jump right into questions then we could
talk a little bit more about what we
might want to cover the future but for
now Jake I'll let you read the first
question we got through Twitter first
one was space cowboy spike Spiegel and
he actually is a fan of the show he
submitted a couple questions at this
point yeah I think what he said is not a
big not a big FPS fan but there a few
exceptions Wolfenstein the new order
titanfall 2 does Metro fall in this
category I think it falls in the
category of Wolfenstein the new order
maybe not titanfall however titanfall is
still a really good shooter but it's not
a story-driven shooter as you were
mentioning before like Wolfenstein is
and this game is definitely in the vein
of
story based shooter mm-hmm yeah as far
as titanfall 2 goes it has a fantastic
campaign but I don't play for the story
I play it more for the design and the
pacing the actual ways it makes use of
that movement from the pilots or the
kind of net combat in the Titans but
well inside the order I think is a
better example because yeah it's a very
story driven the pacing of Wolfenstein
is a lot more arcadey your dual wielding
assault rifles and shotguns and you are
picking up health and I'm not I would
say if you're into more slower paced
shooters like I think again half-life 2
is a good comparison I'd have to say I
don't know something more like if you
played Bioshock in a really difficult
setting it might be more like that
there's the survival and there's the
stealth kind of aspects the blend of
that as you're kind of going through
this linear yet like sandbox area focus
games you might like it so yeah
Wolfenstein is a good
because it has those linear sections
followed by these playground areas where
you can kind of approach it through
stealth especially if you're playing the
expansion the old blood but then kind of
shift frantically to combat and I think
Metro last light shows that in a great
way and also how you can manipulate your
environment so if you're if you've been
playing a lot of titanfall - Metro will
feel very very slow to you yes he's been
playing Wolfenstein it might be more
that speed but more grounded story than
Wolfenstein not as it's alternate
history but it's more you know future or
alternate history if that makes sense
post-apocalyptic play 2033 a fantastic
game not as polished at all once they
got more backing from Koch media who
bought them who bought the rights to it
after the THQ dissolution when once THQ
realized that Metro 2033 was worth or
sorry Metro last light was worth funding
after there's a cult success of Metro
2033 you know it's weird to think about
what 2033 would have been if they had
the funding that the sequel did
now Exodus looks like it's getting a ton
of attention which is great because I
think they deserve it for it's a great
developer that doesn't really get talked
about too much yeah exists looks rad -
so spike Spiegel thank you so much as
you think you are contributing ok cool
here on YouTube I believe right this is
these are YouTube's Mitch former given
that Metro Exodus will be borrowing
heavily from the similarly themed
stalker games do you think the former
will in some way revitalize the latter's
design and spirit so yeah initially
Metro Exodus we thought was gonna be an
open world survival game a la stalker or
like a more shooter based fallout but
they said it would be more in line with
last slight kind of this Lin more linear
game you're traveling from Moscow out to
the outskirts like away from the
radiation so you won't need a gas mask
on the surface as much as as I've heard
but that's beside the point my point
being stalker itself is this kind of big
sandbox area obviously in the shadow of
Chernobyl irradiated irradiated area
kind of survival focused more
atmospheric and exit this is gonna be
more like less like these linear
sections followed by these sand boxes
that they said like the demo they showed
or just kind of dilapidated town where
some of the no solace is were attacking
them in the tunnels before Artyom Artyom
we'll talk about that pronunciation a
second where he emerged from the tunnels
again
so it'll be more of like you know
uncharted does that same thing linear
than these sand boxes and linear these
sandbox is half life 2 did the same
thing I think in terms of spirit and
atmosphere it might allude to stalker in
a lot of ways in many ways which they've
talked about and it actually kind of got
me thinking I want to go back and try
soccer out not polish what's in a lot of
ways but worth checking out
shadow Chernobyl the first one I believe
is the probably my favorite of those but
I don't know Jake what do you think
about what they're going for with exodus
are you interested in the game yeah oh
I'm very interested in Exodus and I
think it just seems like it'll be a more
polished not pop but a bit a more
ambitious version of last slight in
terms of I think the areas you'll be
able to explore bigger more you can
interact with like even in that video it
looked like as as our theme was walking
through you could look in like you could
go inside the different houses and loot
them while I feel like the more
expansive areas in in last light weren't
as detailed there weren't as much to see
and do mm-hmm
yeah but it looks gorgeous yes amazing
they were getting like flack for saying
that was in-game footage that people are
like no that that wasn't a yeah that was
PC footage I think maybe that's what
people thought I think maybe it was like
Windows 10 PC footage not Xbox 1x don't
take my word for I'm not completely sure
but and obviously it's kind of hard to
tell because people for those demos play
at a really slow pace you wouldn't be
like slowly looking when you're playing
so I do yeah I do for good capture
footage yeah yeah well I mean like when
you're just having fun whatever don't
okay cool
i Ju wanna do the next one yes the next
one comes from crime from YouTube and
this isn't so much a question is is just
a comment on the episode overall and he
says none of my friends believed me when
when I said that Metro last light
brought feelings of half-life to a few
years later I see this video I was right
regarding other games the last station
brings some of those feelings it is a 2d
indie game but it still takes me back in
time to the atmosphere I've the
atmosphere similar to half-life I think
that's interesting that other people
also felt that same way cuz I've never
played the original half-life or I've
never played half-life 2 don't kill me
don't kill me
I wrote that episode don't worry I was
yeah he wrote that episode I added half
of
yeah so I I believed him but at the same
time I was like yeah I don't know if
everyone will agree but it was kind of
cool seeing that this guy felt the exact
same way and his friends apparently
didn't believe him you can you can bring
out my name in an argument now because
that's that solves everything yeah no I
mean again it isn't a matter of opinion
but uh yeah again again it was for a
themselves I think it was a head of
communications at the time I forget I
don't think it's John I don't think it's
John who's John Krasinski no have you
been watching a lot of the office no no
that's the only John you could think of
yep all right
but John Hamm but yes they said like
they wanted to rekindle memories of
half-life 2 and you know the Bioshock
has come out
Bioshock 2 BioShock Infinite any number
of narrative driven first-person
shooters like Wolfenstein although that
is a little more arcadey than the ones I
was talking about
um yeah I'm I really like that that kind
of game is being continued that legacy
that game and crime I'm also glad you
recommended the last station I actually
came across that and Steam
recommendations and wasn't sure of it
but now that you mentioned it in
relation to this video I'll probably
check it out that is one thing we didn't
mention in our kickoff episode of this
season another thing that we would want
to see in comments is game
recommendations a lot of people do
recommend them but definitely if you
have something that relates to our last
episode or something we might want to
cover next episode throw that at us like
it's one of the best things you can do
get is a good recommendation for people
whose tastes you trust and everything uh
so thank you crime and finally the last
question I think that's all you alright
Metro last light does continue the
legacy of half-life 2 as a plot driven
first-person shooter but I think it
falls short in both level design and
overall gameplay when compared to
half-life 2 Metro does have great
atmosphere though that was from
breadstick gaming TV on YouTube so I
once it's like I said I haven't played
half-life 2 so I can't really answer
this question but I figured it might be
good for you to elaborate on your
thoughts on this um yeah no I agree
breadstick gaming
I think half-life 2 in terms of level
design is on par with last slide
actually I like how less light
modernizes those sandbox areas and
actually incorporates stealth whereas
half-life 2 is just a lot shooter in
terms of atmosphere I agree Leslie I
think that
fear is even better than half-life 2
although in 2004 would have less to
release from valve I think they made
really good use of that the combine kind
of dictatorship over you know city 17
and the surrounding Eastern European
countryside I think they actually now
that atmosphere with the technological
limitations they had as opposed to what
for a games had with less light when
they were working under THQ and then
Koch media and then you know deep silver
and everything publishing it but I
overall key and play that's it they are
tough to compare cuz I did go into the
stealth a little bit in last light so
they are in terms of pacing different
games but the pacing itself going
through the story is similar and like
how there's a vehicle section and then
there's this kind of like slower section
then there's this more very tightly
designed section like the bridges I
noticed like 3/4 way through the game
they both have this bridge that you kind
of had to methodically move through it
and have left to your fighting combine
soldiers in last light you're fighting
on no solace as those post apocalyptic
creatures but I can ask you about more
about the actual level design of less
light but I do think half-life 2 is
still the better game objectively or not
objectively subjectively because in my
opinion but last light I think is still
very very underappreciated one of the
better shooters ever made in terms of
how it uses the first-person shooter to
tell a story and build a world where
others might not I think this built a
better world than BioShock Infinite like
hands down yeah I agree I think one key
difference though you have to consider
is that the metro series was based on an
already established universe that from a
book wall Bioshock lists I guess just
from Ken Levine yeah sure BioShock
Infinite I think I think Bioshock 1 that
and diverse is pretty tough to compete
with but I think it definitely does I
think both games are head-to-head I'd
say yeah the variety of environments
that you get from being underground
solely is crazy like you go into these
towns it like are like clapboard kind of
2x4 shanty towns but then you go along
this river they call Venice like
ironically almost and then you find new
enemies there you go up to the surface
and it's like much harder to find your
way around even like an Ranger would
obviously could put your compass up but
the amount and that contributes to the
great pacing right the actual shift in
tones and level design and kind
the approach to combat in each section
it I that game pulls me through so
easily I didn't really mention it in the
episode but that Red Square showdown
with Pavel I won't spoil it but if you
know what I'm talking about
oh my god that's that is the biggest
misstep in the game I don't remember
that being what was happening especially
on Ranger mode I don't know who thought
you know they're trying to they were
trying to like introduce the wheel after
they'd already like perfected it the
first three quarters the game they'll
sudden this happens if you've played
last light you know what I'm talking
about when you show now
Pavel but anyway yeah well one thing I
also like to is kind of an aside but I
liked how the the lighter you could use
is like a navigation device like
wherever the the flame blue is where you
could go I didn't know that yeah oh
really yeah like in the tunnels because
you're going to trying to get out yeah
yeah so he can ladies like cobwebs too
yeah that's awesome I don't know that uh
yeah that game is fantastic I already
want to replay it uh get redux on Steam
I'm not sure if it's still on sale as of
the time you're viewing this but it's
well worth it it's already a good value
at its full price of like twenty dollars
or whatever for the Asian Games now 24
both yeah and 2033 is upgraded with last
night's visuals and they're both like up
rezzed for modern like pcs or ps4 Xbox
one whatever you wanna play it on but
yeah they're well worth playing and have
left to you should get on that it's
still fun to clash problem I replayed
the whole thing alongside last night it
was a fun week for me in terms of
research and capturing yeah as I said we
are gonna like tease our next episode as
much it's still kind of hovering between
two ideas right now but I think this
would be a good opportunity now that
we've done one episode this season if
you are a regular viewer and you want to
go back and finish our earlier episodes
and catch up leave in the comments games
that are gonna be coming out later this
summer or in the fall or in early in the
spring next year that you think you'd
like me and Jake to look into and kind
of like look at a different way that
like reviewers might not or people like
like is there a specific game like last
light that is relevant now because I
Exodus got announced or you know
something like maybe with far cry 5
coming on February if we could look back
at earlier far cries and kind of see
where the series has gone something like
that anything if you have any ideas like
months down the road give us ideas
because we have a huge list both of our
ideas and just like the fan suggestion
ideas so we always appreciate that
that's the best part of the show and
obviously if you're watching this on
youtube or GameSpot after the fact we
really appreciate you contributing like
these people did today and we'll be back
yeah I I just wanted to like give a
shout out to a lot of people who I see
like the same people in the comments
almost every week and it's really cool
to see that and then I think I've said
it before too but if you want a better
chance of seeing your question on the
show it's easier to tweet it at us
because it doesn't get buried as easily
especially because both of us can see
those if they're tweeted at us so if
like I miss it he could catch it or if
he catches or if he misses that I could
catch it one of the other yeah more
people did that last week which is super
helpful a little easier to archive those
questions and have them ready for the
off week episodes but we will be back as
usual next week if you keep an eye on
our Twitter accounts we might be teasing
it once we get closer but until then
have a good week see ya
[Music]